what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to Andrew Tate on Pierce
Morgan but before I start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification Bell that we are going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it sign up for one of our four
membership tiers the first gets you to
be part of the live chat during the show
that I do four times a week called the
pregame the second you get access to our
Discord and our Vlogs the third you get
a wanna you get to connect with me on
social media and the fourth you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
okay so
um
I have heard this video going around but
don't know exactly what happens I'm
gonna watch who's working on sensor one
of the most infamous men in the world
Andrew Tate's misogynistic tirade have
been viewed billions of Times online
he's now been effectively banned though
from the internet he doesn't think
that's fair tonight I'm going to try and
work out if it is
from London this is Mrs Morgan okay I'd
like to say Andrew Tate I'm a little
salty you came to London and didn't come
on my show I mean I'm gonna try to watch
this fairly okay and give you a fair
assessment but you're if you're in
London why don't you come on my show
like couple girl out
respectfully please you know if you're
back here you know please come
well good evening from London and
welcome to special edition of Piers
Morgan uncensored Andrew Tate one on one
he's the most famous man you probably
never heard of with billions of views
online at one point this year more
people were searching Google for Andrew
Tate and Donald Trump or Kim Kardashian
former professional kickboxer he was
kicked off big brother in 2016 after a
video emerged of him striking a woman
and what they now both claim was the
consensual sex game he's since made
Millions as a pornographer and casino
owner in Romania but as his online
videos that have made him notorious
across the world posing as a Playboy
with fast cars cigars weapons and cash
he rant about his often scandalous views
on women or instruct a female to provide
sustenance
cook so I think my sister is my her
husband's property yes tell young men
they can get as rich as him by paying
for his digital life lessons
I have a hundred business tips I'm going
to teach you which will allow you to
make your own money instantly but
admitted Global media backlash the net
has closed the man who takes while
Millions still share his videos it's
effectively banned from the web booted
off Facebook YouTube Instagram Twitter
and Tick Tock to his fans is a
misunderstood satirist and the victim of
big Tech censorship to many others he's
a malicious misogynist tonight I'll try
and get to the truth
well some of the opinions Andrew Tate
shares in his videos are undeniably
deeply offensive we're going to show you
some of them on this show I think you
should see them yourself not simply hear
what he says about them or what other if
you're offended by Andrew Tate you're
soft soft this is to Pierce Morgan I'll
invite you on my show too you're in
London I don't know I can't see him
doing YouTube shows but if you're
offended by Andrew Tate beta soft
peoples anyways tens of millions of
people across the world follow Andrew
Tate and with a big Following comes a
big responsibility as well as a public
interest in holding his views to account
if outrageous opinions are read aloud
they can be challenged and exposed for
what they are do you think a big
following has a big responsibility I
guess but then I think of okay this is
how my brain works then I'm thinking of
some people with big followings and I'm
like like Trisha paid us very
entertaining woman she has a big
following but does she have a
responsibility to her followers wait not
she crazy it the people that know who
I'm talking about but yeah I guess yeah
yeah you could say you do you could yeah
I'd say overall silenced the person
holding these views can become a martyr
so that's why I invited Andrew Tate to
come here tonight and he joins me now
live so Andrew well welcome first of all
um you come all the way from Romania to
do this interview correct what what do
you hope to achieve from this interview
why are you here it'd be interesting to
have a conversation with you you've
certainly been uh the subject of your
own divided opinions in the world uh
there's a lot of people who would say
some of the things you say are perhaps
dangerous or toxic so I thought you'd be
a good person to speak to about this
subject I didn't know much about you
before this year and then I suddenly
became very aware of you as the world
did because as I said earlier you you
were the number one subject searched on
Google ahead of Donald Trump I don't
think it was even possible why did you
get suddenly so popular stroke Infamous
do you think I exploded uh I certainly
didn't do that with magic I've been on
the internet for a very long time I
think in the world we live in now as the
other side the other side the people who
disagree with me as they get more and
more tyrannical in their censorships and
their hate mobs Etc as standard
masculine practices are deemed toxic I
didn't put a magic spell on everybody I
managed to accumulate a large amount of
affinity with the male populace Across
the Western world because I'm simply
saying things that many men believe
think and feel the problem I would say
is I want to play you just a clip off
the top this is from Joe Rogan he's
somebody I absolutely love sure and I
think it explains to me what my what I
presume my issue with you is going to be
right correct and you you have
absolutely got the right to try and
persuade me otherwise sure but Joe Rogan
said this about you
my 12 year old and my 14 year old asked
me about Andrew Tate
I said he's a legit world champion
kickboxer I like him a lot why do you
like him and I was asking him they said
he says a lot of funny stuff on on
Twitter and Tick Tock he [ __ ] up with
the misogynist yes because if he didn't
do that if he just had the pro mail
stuff wait did Joe Rogan say he was a
misogynist
a blessing did you were you listening
did Joe Rogan say he was misogynist no
no no he implied it but not is Joe Rogan
soft
not Joe Rogan no
no I'm Gonna Keep listening but I'm
still salty Andrew if you see this I'm
still salty with you for not coming on
my show in London okay I don't yeah it
was interesting because when I've gone
over everything that's been at the
center of the debate about Andrew Tate I
come down with Joe Rogan in the sense
that there's a lot of stuff you say I
agree with you know I've got three sons
in their twenties it's not easy actually
being a young male in the modern world
um and I think a lot of the things that
you say about that uh can resonate with
them the problem comes with the I don't
know 10 20 or whatever of your output
which on the face of it appears to be
blatant misogyny and when you couple
that with your massive influence Clayton
misogyny I'm so tired of men telling me
what's misogynistic now don't get me
wrong there's a lot of women that will
also say the same thing
but I'm used to women spouting nonsense
it's like all right let's let's see what
did he say that was so misogynistic I
just whenever I hear the word misogyny
in my head I'm like these people are
soft because usually whenever like it's
so-called misogyny it's like not
misogyny it's just
people being soft anyways huge reach
that is why the social media companies
have decided to effectively cancel you I
don't believe in cancellation I don't
believe in censorship particularly
that's why I've invited you to come on
the show
um but I do think a lot of the things
you've said are blatant misogyny do you
accept that so you made a very
interesting point there you just said on
the face of it appear to be blatantly
misogynistic I understand that on the
face of some of the long format content
I've made if you're going to take a few
seconds out of hours chop it up put it
all over social media accompany with my
massive Fame then things can absolutely
not really be taken out of context I do
not hate women in any regard I have no
negative relationship with women no
women have come forward saying I've hurt
them I've no criminal record for hurting
women there's no way I can be seen as
the face or the devil in regards to how
men treat women on on the planet I'm
absolutely not really the opposite I
believe in protecting and providing I've
been misunderstood there's been large
contingents of people who have tried
very hard to purport lies about me and
and the the truth of the matter is I've
been producing content for a very long
time hours and hours of videos been cut
down to two or three seconds of clip
those clips have gone viral and people
misunderstand me I think you
you've taken out of context and I'm not
I'm not sure that is correct in the
sense that it still comes out of your
mouth okay okay yeah yeah let's let's
talk about this taken out of context now
I'm a woman so of course I'm gonna make
this about me
of course
I this has happened to me before okay
where I say something and these like for
example for example recently recently I
was taken out of context because I said
that I can't remember what I said
but it was something along the lines of
if if you're obese you don't deserve a
man that makes six figures now I didn't
think this was crazy because they didn't
talk about how I said nobody deserves a
man that makes six figures I don't think
an IG model deserves it but like the
problem is we have big women saying
they're entitled to love anyways that's
a whole other tangent but I understand
what he's saying well things may come
out of your mouth if they clip it up to
15 20 seconds which some shorts are it's
you might think it means something else
but I stand by what I said if you're
over 300 pounds if you're obese you
don't deserve a man that makes six
figures if you get one you're lucky I
think if anyone yeah lucky lucky you
said I just think ah blatantly well
let's do let's do them well let's hear
them let's go through something sure
right so you said this about me too
stroke rate this is probably 40 of the
reason I moved to Romania in Eastern
Europe none of this garbage flies you go
to the police and say he raped me back
in 1988 they'll say well you should have
done something about it back then yeah
so the point I was making was obviously
at the height of the metoo Scandal and
also if we look at Amber Heard and
Johnny Depp there's been a lot of high
profile cases where men have been
accused of things they did not do
without evidence their lives have been
completely and utterly destroyed when I
say these things people sit and say that
oh he hates women I don't hate women I
think rape is disgusting I would take a
stronger stance on rape than the British
government I think these people should
face the death penalty but to sit and
say that women without evidence can go
forward and just make up accusations
against men even though they've been
repeatedly proven to destroy men's lives
at will is absolutely what about a woman
who was raped back in 1988 and goes to
the police then the man should face
absolutely complete Justice
did you understand that when that clip
appears on tick tock as a clip and all
right that's a clip completely okay but
it's still something came out of your
mouth do you accept that when that
appears on Tick Tock a lot of young
maybe not as smart as you young men
right impressionable teenagers we'll
read that and go what's he saying here
is he saying that rape doesn't exist no
I see I don't like when we treat people
like they're stupid now I think anyone
that is grown and even when I was a
teenager if I saw something I understand
that there's context like just because
they're 15 16 this doesn't mean they're
they're like low IQ I don't know I think
that most people unless you're like
disabled have a basic level of like
Common Sense deep down in there even
though Society is trying to brainwash it
out of us so I don't I don't like the
it's your job to hold you hold people's
hand and tell them that there's Nuance
in everything you say like I think
that's just a general truth very
disgusting of course everybody should be
punished for their crimes also don't
think this is misogynistic so far when
they happen but people are not perfect
male and female and if you give women
the opportunity to destroy men's lives
without evidence there's going to be a
contingent of women who will do that I'm
trying to make a balanced and nuanced
argument in a world where people have no
intention span they're going to take a
few seconds put it online decide
someone's good or bad not be interested
in the longer format video and here I am
no I'm certainly a person who takes
personal responsibility that's who I am
as a person but we live in a world now
with Tick Tock videos five or six
seconds long there's no content do you
think do you think women are the
property of men no the point I was like
why have you said they are because I
made a religious point I said that when
a man marries a woman the woman's father
walks him down the aisle walks her down
the aisle and hands her way to the man
traditionally this is what it says in
the Bible I'm a religious person I
believe in God I live in the Muslim so
you do think that the woman becomes the
men I think she takes his last name I
mean let's watch the clip that you said
about sure so that we can get it in
context
so I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false but but I've been
married twice as it turns out and on
both occasions did they leave who
divorced too I'm just he just gives me
Vibes like that respectfully sorry
Pierce I just I just I sense a little as
a woman we can we can smell the simp on
you and I smell I smell it and and I
heard he sent from Meghan Markle it's
like red flag red I know I'm in in
London I think the people like her here
I don't really know but she she screams
red flag to me just you know and yeah
I'm gonna continue I didn't believe that
the woman was being handed to me as
chattel as property it and perhaps the
way that that the reason I'm asked that
question repeatedly and I'm asked in a
loaded way so would you rephrase what
you said there now what that's that's an
interesting point about phrasing the way
I would say things before I was famous I
have to take personal responsibility and
accept right that if I make a video that
500 people see and one percent of them
misunderstand it that's not a problem if
I make a video that five million people
see and one percent of them under so
specifically on that point I think my
sister is a husband's property she took
his last name she she married him she
wanted to join his family she has seen
it herself right so she she's still a
sovereign individual she's absolutely
property means that the husband owns
your sister listen my friend if you want
to argue about this we need to go back
to the Bible to the Quran you need to
argue with religious no no I'm not
talking about anything in the Bible
that's what it says no I'm asking you
what you think I think that if a woman
marries a man and she decides to take
his last name that they have different
roles and responsibilities within that
marriage and I believe that that's all
the way she's I agree
yeah when I get married I want to be
property that sounds fun
I'm with it I don't
I don't understand why people are so
bent out of shape it's like you know
what he's saying you know
that he's not saying like they own you
forever and you can't leave and you have
to do exactly what they say but it's
like if a guy is going to marry you like
you represent him and you're building a
family together and if you want him to
lead the family which most women do they
want a guy that leads and in a way you
kind of are his property yeah let me
I'll be I'll I'll say that on my wedding
day I'll be like I'm property yes and I
believe
like a politician the father hands her
to the man right but don't be a police
station because I think you're a
straight talker right you keep telling
me you're straight talk I think my
sister is her husband's property do you
regret saying it like that I I
understand that with my newfound Fame
perhaps it could be phrased differently
however I still believe that a woman is
given to the man in marriage that's what
I believe yeah but not as property now
the property is the word that other
people use the question but as a an
equal partner in a loving Union that's
what marriage actually means it doesn't
mean that when you get married the woman
is getting I I don't like the term equal
partner her like Pierce I knew I smelled
a little simp in you I blessing do you
want an equal partner
no
you don't want an equal partner is your
girl gonna be your property he's like
you can't go that far
um yeah I I could have told you I'm like
this is why you got ghosted by Meghan
Markle Pierce I said it to you as a bit
of chocolate agreed and like you know
it's like to get he got ghosted by a
crazy lady I don't care what any of you
all say any any woman that has her man
so far in her the palm of her hand that
can convince him to leave his whole
family his country and give up the
throne she's gotta be nuts she's gotta
be no I don't I don't care any of you
also I know you all like her here or
don't I don't I don't know do you guys
like her here I thought you did it's
like 50 50. yeah but why but that's the
way that people ask me the question
people say to me they asked me you can't
blame people for asking you questions
surely if you want to be accountable for
what you said you've got to own your
responses don't blame the question I own
the response let me ask you a question
no and you say something and then say
well I should blame you for us I
understand peers peers I understand I
believe the woman is given to the man I
believe she's given away by the father I
believe she belongs to the man
fundamentally right so fundamentally you
do believe that a woman becomes a man's
property I believe she belongs to the
man in marriage correct right
oh you see that to me is misogyny and
you're entitled to your opinion right
but do you want do you not understand
why people think it is misogyny I
understand why some people can be very
offended by what I say what they do is
they take a point like that and they
ignore all the other points I make the
other way right that's why that's why
I've repeatedly asked you about that
line and it any tall handsome man call
me I'll be your property
sorry I can't I can't I can't I can't
um
okay okay
um
I mean I said it before I knew when I
when I I don't know much about Pierce
Morgan I saw him get destroyed by Ben
Shapiro a couple years ago that was
hilarious and every time I see him like
I've only seen him a couple times and
every time he's getting destroyed by
someone
so I'm like
he just seems to go viral for the wrong
reasons like what like what else does he
do other than get destroyed by people
what is he big here yeah
I I swear to God I've only seen him when
he's getting owned by somebody
oh that's what he's like known for
to see if you've changed your position
but the reality is you haven't it's not
about changing positions I'm a
full-grown adult and I stick by the
things I say and I'm responsible for
them which by the way is fine absolutely
so what you did say at the start of this
little exchange you said you know I
wouldn't maybe say things the same way
now that I did before I was famous and
yet actually you've doubled done it's an
exactly the same thing on certain points
so that is what you believe that's my
point yes I'm trying to work out look I
don't know you we just met right yeah
I'm trying to work out who Andrew and
you're leaving a hell of a first
impression Pierce
Pierce
like you could
he's already grilling it okay okay
what you actually believe I don't want
to twist anything at all then maybe make
it very very clear to the camera I
believe a woman is given to the man in
marriage I believe that I also believe a
man has a duty to protect and provide
for her I believe a man should lay down
his life if something happens or his
wife's life is threatened I believe that
Women and Children First are on the
light boat lifeboats but maybe I believe
that men but a man doesn't own a woman
it's not no it's honestly literally buy
them as a slave well obviously we're not
talking about that we're talking about
religious biblical marriage we're
talking about something else yeah but
I'm a Christian I don't believe that I I
I I own my wife do you believe your wife
was given away to you you know that
makes a lot of sense there's a lot of
symptoms in the Christian church like I
mean
it wasn't always like this I don't think
and this is coming like you know I'd
consider myself Christian but
Pierce Pierce Pierce
I believe
do you think is he married still oh he's
single
I was just he just gives me the Vibes of
someone who'd get like married and get
taken half I don't know
it's just like The Vibes I mean I I
don't know you pierce I'm sorry I'm
sorry okay there was a process where a
father traditionally walks his daughter
down the aisle and hands his daughter to
this man and they stand there and become
a union of two loving people in a
partnership no there's no ownership
involved I didn't say he's not selling
her the Father of the Bride isn't
selling his daughter no absolutely means
he becomes a member of your family I
think we're arguing over semantics
because fundamentally I don't believe a
man owns a woman you do well I don't
think a man owns any sovereign
individual I don't think we live in the
world of slavery I don't own any man or
any woman right nobody owns it when you
use phrases like property that's what
you imply that's understanding and so my
point again is you're a smart guy it's
like okay it's like if if check where
you work so it's like you get to pick
your your property owner
it's like yeah yeah and you can you can
leave and take half you actually get
paid to leave and take half so I
wouldn't
I wouldn't really
paint with like that is misogynistic
it's just more like hey you pick your
boss
and if you leave you get a severance
package yep Pierce there's no denying
that you're smart you're a good talker
I've seen a lot of stuff but when you
what what I don't think you quite fully
understand no I understand when young
impressionable people I understand you
are not as smart see things like I think
my sister is a husband's property yes
and you've just reaffirmed that that
belief they think that they have the
right to own women I understand that
very well Pierce which that's why people
think you're a massage completely I
understand all of this very well which
is why when you're saying I was
backtracking I'm not I'm generally
regret that over the way you phrase this
stuff well this is the point I was
trying to make
the point I'm trying to make is when I
was not nearly as famous and I was
making long format content I was not
sitting there anticipating I'd become
the most Googled man in the planet and
that few seconds can be taken out of
context that was not my anticipation but
it's not what you believed it's what you
believe now so what's the difference
it's not about it's not you're asking me
you're saying that young people who are
impressed you said to me look look peers
honestly I've had time to think about
this and I wish I hadn't said it I don't
believe that that's one thing actually
you've said the opposite you said
actually that's what I think yeah I
think that when uh so it doesn't really
matter whether you recorded it when you
famous or not famous it's what you
actually believe right I believe that a
man has a duty to protect and provide
for a woman I believe that uh a woman's
father gives her away to the man that's
what I believe and that's in in my
marriage that's that's the circumstance
I'm going to live under if people want
to live in a different scenario that's
completely theirs they're they're
prerogative you went on to say about
authority over women if I have a
responsibility over I must have a degree
of authority yeah for the same reason if
I have responsibility over and people
are going to lose their mind it's an
example an energy responsibility over a
child I have to have some Authority so
you believe as part of your ownership or
your property of of the woman you have
authority over her no I believe if you
ever that's what you said I believe
you've ever responsibility over
something you have to have a degree of
authority you can't be responsible but
Authority means again that you're the
boss the point I'm making if you'll
please let me finish at this point the
point I was trying to make was talking
about the safety of a woman she was
walking alone at night and I was saying
well I wouldn't let my woman walk alone
at night and they said well you're not
in charge of her you don't get to decide
what she does I say I understand but if
I'm responsible for her safety and I'm
the person who's burdened with making
sure she is safe I have to have the
authority to say don't put yourself in
unsafe situations the two things are
linked well you know you're an authority
you have the you could absolutely have
the right to say to the woman you're
with I don't think you should but
ultimately if she decides that I can't
force her right so Authority implies
that you have the ability to control
someone now Authority believes the
authority implies that I have the moral
right to sit and say that that's an
irresponsible thing to do and I'm
responsible that's not what Authority
means well I'm not gonna if you think
I'm gonna lock somebody up in their room
if that's is that what you're implying
no I just think I don't think you know
what Authority means I know what it
means I'm saying that about this is a
different description of what Authority
if I have responsibility okay Pierce do
you want to bet you doesn't listen to
you
is that what you want like he said the
same thing like five times
if he's in charge of making her sure she
doesn't get killed and you know she's
protected then
yeah she's she should listen I I'm not
offended these people why is a grown ass
man
soft soft for her safety then I have to
have the authority to tell her not to do
unsafe yeah but Authority means that you
have some form of control over it sorry
I'm trying to work on being more
feminine hold on hold on hold on
soft this woman
I I think you're trying to what you're
trying to do I'm only trying to get to
what you think honestly I am I come with
No Agenda here at all I understand and
I'm explaining very very clearly if I
have responsibility over said subject I
have to have authority of it so let me
say you have children right right you
have responsibility for them I have I
have legal authority over my children
that is very different having legal
authority over my wife or my female
partner completely but the point I'm
trying to make so you accept that I I
accept it you use the analogy of
responsibility for a child my friend
these are these are very these are
actually really important things they're
important things but you introduce you
introduce you interrupt me every five
seconds so it's hard for me to actually
explain my point the point I'm making
here is very simple you have children
and you're responsible for their safety
so you're going to have authority to say
don't go out at night perhaps because
you want them to be safe you have legal
Authority you have a legal Authority
yeah legal Authority I'm saying that if
I had a woman and the question where
you've raised a sound bite from I was
asked about protecting a woman making
sure she's safe and I would say I
wouldn't want her to go out at night on
her own because I'm responsible for her
safety and someone said well does that
sound like a [ __ ] you'd want to date
blessing like I think so I want to walk
home alone at night and you say yeah
don't do that well I'm doing it anyway
and you're not responsible for me like
you're you're breaking up with her
like he's not red pill he's just African
try it
yeah he's done he's done
don't have a story over to do that and I
said well no I can't force her to stay
inside but if she were to ask me how do
I protect myself at night I would say
well you should stay inside that's how
you should do it that's I don't have an
issue with so we agree no it's the
semantics no it's not it's not semantic
so this is what I don't think you quite
get why there's a fury over what you say
with respect because the semantics point
would be if we're saying the same thing
in different ways but we're not I'm
saying to you when you say I have to
have some authority over a woman I say
to you you have no right to any
authority over a woman you do over a
child if it's your child because you are
the legal appointed guardian of that
child you're not a legally appointed
guardian or authority over your wife or
female legally appointed absolutely not
I agree however
when it comes to things like personal
response to your personal safety men
largely by Society are accepted we're
the protectors and providers we can sit
here and pretend in the world we live in
if me and my wife were walking down the
street and men were to come up and try
and attack us I wouldn't be the one
fighting but we both know in reality I
would right I have a degree I have a
degree of responsibility to protect her
so if I have a degree of responsibility
to protect her physically then the point
I'm trying to make is I will do my best
to make sure she's never put herself you
wish you hadn't used the word Authority
The Authority is something that she
would give to me she would come to me
and say how do how can I make sure
I don't interrupt you I just want to
point out that's not what Authority
means if someone gives you can a person
can get voluntary Authority is not
Authority no but that's the point
Pierce if a woman comes to me and says I
want you to keep me safe she is handing
me Authority for her safety but do you
understand the difference between having
authority over somebody and somebody
giving you permission to have authority
completely I never said what is
consensual and one isn't but why are we
pretending I do unconsensual things
because you literally say I must have a
degree of authority I have to have some
Authority and the point is
peer
for a man that's in this high up of a
position how do you not understand what
he's saying like it's just so clear like
he's saying that like if she's in the
position of being his woman she has
given him the authority not he Shackled
her and made her stay home and not walk
her home alone at dark alleys at night
he just said like yeah if if this is my
girl she's giving me some of the peers
this is why you keep going viral for the
wrong reasons and I I know this is
edited too I really want to see the full
uncut thing release all of it release
all of it responsible for her safety if
I'm not responsible for a single
position if your position now is that
with her permission I would like to have
authority when we go out at night to
protect it oh my God I would like to
have authority over you like
that was always my position that's not
what you said but that was always my
position so again I simply say to you do
you it is what I said do you wish you'd
phrased it a different way no because
we're talking about long format copy
where I'm talking about a woman who has
come to me and said you're responsible
for making sure I'm safe I said well
then I have to make the decisions but an
18 year old boy reads I must have some
authority over a woman what do you think
he thinks well I understand that and I
said this earlier when you tried the
sales backtracking which I'm not doing
no I'm not trying to get to you cool I'm
trying to work out exactly what you I
understand with massive Fame comes
massive responsibility I understand that
a percentage of the population are
always going to take everything that's
said by anybody out of context would you
change the wording of what you said no I
would just encourage people to watch my
long format copy and understand would
you tell an 18 year old boy you don't
have authority over women absolutely you
would say that unless a woman comes to
him and says you're responsible for my
safety please make sure keep me safe
Andrew Tate I can sign up to well then
we agree yeah but I don't agree with
what you said before because you're
taking a sound bite from a two hour but
you haven't been taken out of context
because I read you the entire sentence
it's very you've ignored all the context
around the sentence my friend you can't
ignore a sentence that says I must have
a degree of authority but you can win
that there's a two-hour conversation
where a woman is telling me if she makes
me responsible for her safety and me
explaining well if I'm responsible for
your safety I have the authority to make
decisions yes do you respect women
absolutely why wouldn't I do you think
the 18 19 year old woman are more
attractive than 25 year old woman I
think there's Attractive people uh
that's that's a loaded question I don't
know it's not real is it I I can't know
why I'm asking of course I do but I
can't sit here and so the benefit of you
is you don't know why I'm asking you
said this in general this is also one of
the reasons men find youth attractive
you want to blow up the internet or
block the internet write a thing now the
reason 18 and 19 year olds are more
attractive than 25 year olds is because
they've been through less I'm 25.
dick people say oh you can't say that
but yes I can a 19 year old is more
attractive than 26 year old woman and
I'll tell you why because that 26 year
old has talked to more guys been to the
club more times being effed and dumped
more times more arguments more mass more
for me to clean up that
is misogyny why because you are
encouraging a mindset about 25 year old
women that make some sound out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds and having effectively been
having too much sex to be taken in a
more respectful way that would well
firstly even if that was the case that
wouldn't be misogyny but what did you
mean by what you said that's not
misogyny because it's not anti-women I'm
saying that an 18 or a 19 year old woman
would be more desired 25 year old woman
Auntie 25 year old women we can argue
but not misogynistic well that's massage
that's no no no it's not being anti-any
woman at all is misogyny not when I'm
not what I'm saying that women are
beautiful and attractive at a certain
age and saying the ages you're saying 18
19 years are more attractive than 20
years than ageist perhaps but
misogynistic absolutely but you just
accepted it was misogyny no I didn't you
said it was okay would it be a misogyny
if he said that 25 year olds are more
attractive than 45 year olds
like I've been staying since I was a kid
most people that I know peek at like 18
19.
I swear to God
I swear to God
like and then he's gonna say okay
when I when I was 18 I was a virgin I'm
not a virgin now I was probably more
desirable then like I don't
I don't think that's crazy like this
feels soft
you know what this a generation of soft
people
okay I'm 25 I'm not offended like stop
it stop it it's on your no it's not hot
so you don't think if you're saying
slightly hateful things about it it's
not slightly hateful well it is you
think you you said and how is it hateful
to just say like
25 year olds are less desirable than 18
year olds in general I like honestly in
the U.S half the 25 year olds are fat
like half y'all let yourself go look at
it I weigh the same I did when I
graduated high school
now was I a little thick in high school
well but but I'm just saying like half
y'all have gotten fat by the time you're
25. let's just be honest or at least
chunky curvy thick so just by that alone
you're probably better looking at 18.
most people look better younger
especially women I don't know what to
tell you so a woman's face if she's 25
it's not slightly hateful
you could have said that to my face
Andrew if you came on my show you Coulda
as you're a woman and tell her exactly
what I've just read why would I walk up
to a random 25 because you said it in
public it's on the internet and it's
been listened to and watched by millions
and millions of young Impressions there
was a large panel there was a
conversation there was hours Longs of
conversation there were feminists
attacking men for toxic masculinity and
attacking me and saying things and I
said things back which we're going to
enter and I think see I'm I so which
you've done yourself a bunch of times I
think a lot of allegations of toxic
masculinity are not toxic correct I do
think that kind of uh sentence I just
read out that that paragraph is actually
toxic if you genuinely mean that and you
say you wouldn't say it to a woman's
face but you said it in public about
women of that age I do think that's
misogynist and I think you probably do
too I don't think it's misogynistic I
understand why I can be insulting too
you wouldn't say it to a woman's face
well it depends you're making out like
I'm walking around the street going up
to random 25 you're doing it to tens of
millions of people online there's no
difference not at all we're discussing a
topic we were discussing that I ideal
age of a man should young boys right in
their teens are you comfortable that
they would have that mindset be honest I
think that young boys in their teens
lack life experience they lack nuance
and they need to be very very careful
what they're digesting online whether
it's my content or anybody else's I
think you know for a fact millions of
them are digesting exactly what you're
saying completely the entire internet to
a degree I think any any subject you can
find there's going to be a whole I come
back to the Joe Rogan thing Andrew a lot
of what you say I agree with yeah right
I do genuinely I've read a lot I've
written a lot of stuff you said a lot of
the stuff you talk about I think it's
got a good point right so we agree about
a lot of things but when I read that
kind of thing I'm like
I just how much of that is you how much
of that is some ACT do you regret saying
stuff like this I don't actually do you
see it as weakness to admit you
shouldn't have said something like that
no I don't live with regret I think
what's happened is that like I said long
format content arguments with feminists
arguments with the toxic masculine crowd
arguments with the left and they're
going to take a small clip small
sentence from hours and they're going to
try and paint me but I'm not left or
right I don't know what you are Pierce
exactly that's my point that's my point
and I understand and and you're doing
exactly as I knew would happen on this
interview which is because you're a busy
man you're not gonna watch hours and
hours and hours of video actually I have
watched thousand hours of video and I'm
going to come to the stuff where I agree
with you and I'm going to come to the
stuff about your censorship which I have
issues with so this is It's a Long
interview right sure I just thought off
the top you said to me and you were
quite bold about it well go on then
let's go through this and you and you
should keep going I will sit here and
stand by what I said I believe that oh
man on that I just read to you that yeah
do you wish you hadn't said that
I understand how it's been misconstrued
I understand how it's been weaponized
against me do I regret it because it's
been weaponized and used against me well
that's slightly annoying did I that's
not why did I at the time mean what I
said and in the context of the
conversation which obviously you you're
not familiar with and the people at home
are not familiar with no I meant what I
said the 25 year old women have just
talked to more guys been to the club
more times being effed and dumped more
times more arguments More Mess more for
me to clean up well there's a whole much
there's a whole bunch of context and
conversation around that that's been
missed tonight I don't think I'm missing
much context well I I encourage people
who are interested to go watch it right
but I mean I've just read out three
sentences on the bounce there oh boo
freaking who Pierce
I'm a 25 year old woman hello Andrew
Tate I'm too old for Andrew Tate but who
cares who gives like what date your age
soft there's any context I'm missing I
mean you'll you've made it pretty clear
what you think about the difference
between 18 and 90 year old women I
wasn't talking about myself even I was
explaining I was talking with a Muslim
guy who was on the panel and he was
explaining how youth is very valid
valued in most parts of the world and
why Virginia is valued in both parts of
the world and the feminists were arguing
against it and I was sitting there
actually very much like you a mediator
between the two explaining why in most
of the world still today perhaps not in
the Western World Virginia is Coveted
youth is Coveted in most of the world
and per and throughout all of human
history and I was sitting there making
the point explaining why in certain
parts of the world they think how they
do well you know even though it's very
different to the Western World so I was
making a point mediating between two
groups very similar to yourself the
conversation has been misunderstood
they've taken this clip of it and it's
been weaponized and used against me I
understand that it's because I'm now the
most famous Google person on the planet
it's inconvenient in sure but I'm
definitely not a danger to women in any
regard I date women 25 26 27 years old
all the time none of them are offended
by the things I don't think you're a
danger to women I think that I think the
danger if it concerns you oh he goes up
to 27. wow
so there's a chance
[Laughter]
um
I feel like I'm just repeating myself
soft soft soft
danger is the influence you have on
young men to have this kind of mindset
about women and that's really where I'm
trying to get to what you really believe
and how much you've just shot off
because you think it's like entertaining
and you haven't really given it much
thought and whether now you're a bit
older and you've had all the Fallout
where the part of you is thinking
actually if I had as Joe Rogan says if
you hadn't said stuff like this you'd
probably still been on these platforms
you'd be massively more popular
massively more famous massively richer
so I'm really just trying to get to on
the blatantly misogynist stuff do you
just wish you hadn't said it with great
power comes great I can't just because
you say it's misogynistic does it make
it misogynistic if you switched that and
said 25 year olds were are more
desirable than 80 year olds because they
haven't been through as much would that
be misogynistic it was certainly said
before the great power came it's
inconvenient to a degree however like I
said at the time with the context of the
conversation I know that I'm not saying
things which I believe to be detrimental
to the world however they've been
misconstrued and they've been
misunderstooded if a 25 year old woman
was watching this would you say I'm
sorry for saying that well I wouldn't
want anyone to be offended by anything I
say but I say things when I say things
that offend and this is the thing that's
interesting Pierce please let me finish
maybe are you again like a politician
hang on you could say I'm interrupting
you do but you're answering a different
question to the one I asked you so as an
interviewer okay sure okay sure okay you
accept that let's accept it okay so
again my point is simply if a 26 year
old woman is watching this and has heard
those comments would you just say to her
look I'm sorry I shouldn't have said
that no I won't I will say that I am
sorry that that offends you however
there's a large contingent of the world
doesn't mean you're sorry stand on it
King stand on it you know what's funny
when I first saw Andrew Tate
I really wasn't I wasn't even the
biggest fan not because of any of this
but like I I saw some video of him
cheating on his girlfriends in front of
each other and I just thought that was
rude they were like crying and he's like
yeah it's kind of funny and I was like
like that man is
it's a bit harsh it's a bit harsh like
that's that's a bit much
but not the more I hear him talk the
more I'm like
I still wouldn't do the cheating party I
feel like even if you got two
girlfriends that's a bit rude right
you'd agree right yeah
but you know you respect it stand on
your words King no I'm not sorry that's
the point I'm making I'm sorry if that
offends you however there's a large
contingent of the world that believed
that and I was mediating for a
conversation parts of the world that
believed that about 26 year old women
are parts of the world where women are
not allowed out on their own that's your
that's a conversation well that's a
conversation they're not allowed to
drive cars honestly I hate driving
anyway
send that back
I much prefer to be in the passenger
seat
something to do with it but is that the
kind of world for a woman I was
mediating I was mediating a conversation
I'm asking you what you think I I don't
live in a country where that happens
you're using that as the excuse for why
you're not sorry for saying it there are
parts of the world but this is fine my
question to you is well do you think
it's fine I don't think it's fine I live
in a world where you don't think it's
fine my the reason this isn't that hard
Andrew you could simply say beers you
know what with the benefit of hindsight
I wish I hadn't said it like that and if
a 26 year old woman's watching I'm sorry
I said that because that actually is
blatantly misogynist and even though
that's a view held by other parts of the
world it's not a view I share now I
would respect you more if you said that
yeah than if you try and say Well it
said in other parts of the world so I'm
not sorry I think that doesn't tell me
what you think then you need to
understand why my content existed in the
first place my content existed because I
tried my very hardest to be an absolute
not a realist especially with
uncomfortable truths I was pointing out
that very uncomfortable is that a truth
it's an uncomfortable truth in many
parts of the world it's not a proof that
I'm happy about it's not true no hang on
you're doing it again what do you mean
that's a truth in other parts of the
world that's what you said it's not
you're not talking about another part of
the world you're talking about what you
believe is the difference between 18 and
90 year olds and 26 year olds I was
talking about your belief I was talking
about what the people on the panel
believe the difference is
so what do you think the difference is I
think the difference is age what's the
difference though well they're 26 year
olds older than the 19 year old and so
you stand by what you said about talking
to the guys been to the club more times
been after dump more times why you
believe that or not no there's plenty of
26 year old women who have been with one
man or a virgin of course so you don't
believe that I don't think that the age
is the only thing that's going to
decipher well how many men or women so
if you don't actually believe what
you're saying just say sorry it's not
about not believing what I'm saying it's
about you understanding that there's
large conversations going on I'm just
reading back stuff you've said I know
you're asking you do you believe it I
believe that it's more likely that 26
year olds had more Partners than a 19
year old right you don't know that I
don't know that you're right in fact
there could be absolutely no evidence
for that whatsoever completely agree so
why say it my stigmatize all 26 year old
women oh God Pierce okay even if the
girl's a virgin at 26
she's probably kissed more guys than
when she was 19.
what age
oh my God it's like like I feel like
this is this point isn't even
controversial let's widen the age Gap 25
and 45. it's just he put the ages too
close together so people can argue but
if you made it like a solid decade like
if you said a 25 year old and a 35 year
old
I think 18 to 28 people would still
argue but if you did 18 to 35 like
stop arguing
it's not about we're repeating ourselves
here but not really I'm just trying to
get to what you actually believe I
believe that men find youth attractive
in general I believe that in the context
of the conversation five-year-old women
aren't old I agree with you they're not
especially they're I'm old you're you
know I'm a lot older than that the point
I was making was part of mediating a
panel a conversation between feminists
and some Muslim guys get it okay you
understand why I said the sentence but
as far as I know you weren't espousing
what a Muslim man might think you were
espousing what you think I was espousing
what the people on the panel believed
but you were saying what you think
is is I I feel like you're trying to pin
me down if it's not what you believe
just say I don't believe that
what part wouldn't I believe well you
tell me which part you don't believe
there's the sentence which part would
you now say you don't believe
I believe that 25 year old women perhaps
have had because they've been alive
longer maybe have had more Partners but
I don't believe that makes them a bad
person right but you understand that the
way you phrased it makes every 25 I
understand you're a bad person no I
don't think
every 25 stop speaking stop mansplaining
yeah Pierce
Angie you're not stupid you know what
that sounds like to any 25 26 year old
woman completely no
stops me
he's putting words in our mouths No
nasty stop it so you have maligned every
what if I went on his show and I said
but you said every and every time you
tried to talk I'd cut him off and I'd be
like no no I'm just using the words that
come out of your mouth Pierce ever you
said every 25 year old why would you say
that when you don't speak for all 25
year olds huh and then he'd be like try
to talk and be like ah
you're answering like a politician
Pierce
you're answering like a politician
yeah
how would you like it Pierce 26 year old
woman but come on Michelle if you're
free you know I'm just saying there we
go let bygones be bygones
with that statement and I'm simply
asking you to all those who are not of
the type of women that you've described
it are you sorry I don't want anybody to
be offended by anything I say I want to
be a positive force in the world I don't
want anybody to hear what I say and make
them feel bad about themselves I want
all people to live righteous and good
whether they're male or female and
anybody you need a righteous life I
think I do yeah do you yeah and you
boasted openly of having six seven
Partners at once so is that righteous
there's no moral View From Me simply
asking you what you think righteous
means I think righteous is living true
to your heart and knowing that you're
doing good by people not snaking anybody
not lying to anybody I know I live a
very righteous life I will say the
cheating part like if I did a cut to the
cheating party right now but I actually
I do think Andrew Tate does he has like
Charities and stuff and he does I do
think he is on he's clearly honest with
his side chicks but I was just thinking
about that just be a funny edit
if you've ever been in love yeah how
many times oh plenty I believe in love
between men and women I'm a real love
you know yeah I believe how many times
would you say enough I believe men and
women are a beautiful Union I think
we're slightly different but when we
work together we're the most powerful
force in the world how many women have
you loved
I don't know pierce my few give me a
Bullpup
5 10 20. let's let's say you don't
forget how many people you've been in
love with let's say 10 I mean I've been
in love and I certainly believe that men
and women when they work together it's
the most beautiful force on the planet I
believe in family I believe in children
I believe in if you believe in family
and children and love yeah why are you
single I'm not single well you're not
married so I mean well if I was married
the last thing I would do is advertise
it to the feral psychopath on the
internet so that's what federal psyched
about well like you call me friend
earlier it can be debated peers but the
point the point but the point I'm making
as a whole is that all of these do you
want to get married if I play no but
let's let's please for example let's
please for a second because you've
interrupted me so many times I've failed
well actually I've only interrupted you
just to be clear when you've actually
answered a different question cool well
then on all these points and you've
admitted that on all these points you're
making on repeat you're making you're
taking these sentences and on repeat
you're using to what you're weaponizing
them against me I'm not weaponizing
anything okay it's fine no no the more
weaponizing the weaponizing that doesn't
exist no problem but you said to me come
on bring it on read out all the things
that you think are blatant misogyny all
I've done is literally read out all the
things we identified from all the
research that I thought were blatantly
misogynist and giving you the chance to
respond and the only time I've
interrupted you is when you've tried to
answer a completely different question
understood peers
the but these things were said in large
context where often I'm talking about
how
for example on the same podcast where
you've read one of them sentences from I
was talking about how it's a man's duty
to die by a woman and the guy asked me
said if 10 men if 10 men with knives
attacked your woman wouldn't you just I
said yeah I'd stand and die I'd never
just run away because I have a duty as a
man I must I must die on the spot to
protect her honor and my honor I'm
talking about a man having
responsibility to his duties I'm talking
about the old traditional ways of
masculinity and what happens is a few
sentences from such a long conversation
is taken and used against it I
understand that so I want you to
understand that I'm talking about
protecting and providing for women I'm
talking about a man you want to get a
marriage no but this is but we have to
we household feed into each other peers
I'm talking about protective questions
no but I'm talking about protecting and
providing for a woman I'm talking about
a man being responsible for her I
understand so of course I believe in men
and women of course I believe in love of
course I believe in marriage of course I
believe in family the idea that I don't
believe in the idea that I don't believe
in these things if you believed it I
asked you if you're going to get married
one day absolutely you'd like to if I'm
not married already I would I will be
married one day if I'm not well you
might be secretly married I I could be
married correct why would you not tell
me either way why would I advertise to
the feral Psychopaths of the world who
have tried their very best to destroy me
for an opinion about my private life and
the things that are most sacred to me
you think if you said you were married
everyone would hate you I don't like
people hate me it's about me
understanding that I'm a hard target but
I am very very protective of the people
I care about right but you believe in
the concept of marriage completely
that's what we were talking about the
whole time what do you think we talked
about a man giving a woman away I
believe in marriage more than anybody I
believe in marriage and no please I
believe in marriage in the traditional
sense I believe a man has a duty to
stand up and be a real man I believe
that the problem with the world today
that we are facing is that not enough
men are sticking to the age-old ways of
masculinity I believe that me standing
up and saying a man must protect a woman
and provide for her so he needs to make
sure that she's safe he needs a degree
of authority I have no problem with no
but no you but people do have a problem
with it and that's not sorry and that's
the rule we're in now I'm over here sure
I don't have a problem with what you
just said here's where my problem comes
right there are a lot of clips of you
floating around on the internet as you
know one of them has you saying bang out
the machete boom in her face grip her by
the neck shut up [ __ ] in another you
say slap slap grab choke shut up [ __ ]
sex
when people see those clips and here you
say those things agree well I don't
think that
it's all hard to misunderstand it it is
you might say that it's consensual other
people would say whether it's consensual
or not that's a very ugly way to talk
about women completely now that's
hitting them with machetes no watch the
whole video it's a girl coming at me
with a machete and me saying he'd slap
the machete out of her hand she's
attacking me so you don't understand
this is the exact point no people don't
watch them in full and this is actually
what's interesting and please don't
interrupt me on this point social media
has changed in Modern Times YouTube five
years ago was five six seven eight
minute long videos now we have Tick Tock
10 seconds 15 seconds 20 seconds YouTube
shorts Instagram stories now anything
you produce as long form is cut down to
very very short form they're interested
in clicks they're interested in
engagements
they find the most controversial Clips
they can on purpose you benefited from
all that everybody benefits from social
media views yes do you yo was it the
Hustler what is it I had an online
school called Hustler's University right
and their whole job was to promote your
Clips make you rich and famous so you've
benefited from this system the one you
now profess to hate you've benefited
from I never said I hate you clickbaited
like the best of them I never said I
hated it I'm saying what happened I
don't hate it I don't hate social media
I think it's a very powerful force I
don't hate the social media I'm saying
that is I think you can talk look you
can talk to girlfriends of yours
um maybe a secret wife I don't know or
two or two you maybe you've got ten
wives that's your business I don't care
right my and the thing is I don't care
what you do in private if you're
consensual between you and another woman
you can do what you like right it's your
life I believe in freedom and liberty
it's when you said in public it's the
influence that this kind of thing has on
young men I agree right and I speak to
someone with three sons right it's well
by the way they're intrigued by you
they're fast yeah girls hate that rough
stuff yeah they did right you're a
you're a big thing in that world of tick
tock and so on I'm just playing I'm just
playing so they always are aware of you
and what you say so they're all looking
And when they see things like the
machete thing I get the context because
I'm a 57 year old guy who's been around
the block a bit and I can get what you
said and you're responding to a
particular scenario which you'd created
where a woman but it can be
misunderstood I understand so my point
to you is given that you know it can be
misunderstood do you regret saying
things like this on camera where it can
be disseminated by less intelligent
young males who think that is actually
what they should be doing to women and
finally we get to the point of the issue
which is the point I tried to make at
the very beginning when I made a video
before I was famous that got 500 views
me being concerned that one percent of
people will misunderstand it was not
relevant we're not you start getting
five million views of video 50 million
views of video one percent of people
misunderstanding doesn't change no it
doesn't but it becomes a much larger
problem so with great Fame that's true
comes great responsibility right so I
agree would I now that I'm famous do I
say things the same way as I did back
before I was famous absolutely not right
as neither would you or nearly any other
famous person on the planet once you
become famous you have to be a lot more
careful with how you say things I
understand so my logical follow-up to
that remains do you regret then saying
it the way you said it I can't live in
regret by saying something before I was
famous on a camera which barely anybody
watched and then I became famous
afterwards that would be a very asinine
way to view the world you can't live and
you stand by all those I can't live in
regret because I didn't know I was gonna
become the most famous man on the planet
that that regret would be the wrong word
is it on is it inconvenient sure but I
can't sit here and say I wish I knew six
years ago I'd be the most famous man on
the planet and monitored all of my
speech forever that's asinine
you see but one of the problems that
people have with you is that
they think you have a malevolent
influence on young people this was the
excuse that was put out by the big Tech
Excuse excuse being the key word well it
may be actually you know I I
intrinsically I have a problem with
censorship I don't think Donald Trump
should be banned from Twitter for
example yeah bring Donald Trump back to
Twitter that man had some fire tweets he
was hilarious bring him back please he
would be tweeting out celebrities and
just calling them like everybody it was
tweeting at Emma Emma the girl from
Twilight for cheating on Robert back in
the day he's like I don't like her
remains on Twitter and other social
media platforms and whatever I think of
you you're not the eye color of Iran
right so there's cop there's a to me
there's got to be perspective here and I
don't understand the inconsistency by
what companies like Twitter how they
treat the the leader of Iran and someone
like you seems to me they're much more
Draconian on people like you yeah than
they are with people who perhaps should
not be allowed platforms
um but generally I don't really agree
with no platforming people yeah but I
think what's interesting talking to you
is it seems to me like you have gone on
a bit of a journey of self-awareness
about the impact of some of the stuff
you said in the past and you have said
you wouldn't say it again in the same
way now you may not want to express
regret for that but it shows me that the
very least you have evolved to somebody
who recognizes that these can be quite
damaging in the way that you said them
completely as a professional and as an
adult it would be stupid for me to sit
here and say that now that I'm the most
famous man on the planet my words do not
have more impact than they did before
with impact with power comes
responsibility and things need to be
worded in a very careful way now when I
do a long Format Interview I have to sit
there and consciously understand that
any 10 seconds of that can be cut and
used against me so I can be a lot more
careful with how I say my words and how
I construct my sentences of course we
agree with all of that that's exactly
what's happened to me I agree with all
of that I don't want to be seen as a
negative influence in the world I know
that there's a whole bunch of men I get
thousands of emails a week from men
whose lives I've saved I get thousands
of emails a week from men who are on the
verge of suicide and I've saved their
lives we're talking about by the way I
don't dispute that at all you have
almost certainly I would think from
everything I've read about you I think
you have certainly been probably able to
be very helpful to young men who have
really struggled for self-confidence and
all that kind of thing right I'm
completely prepared to accept that but
there was also I think quite a
disturbing piece that BuzzFeed did and
it talked about the the negative impact
of young impressionable male Minds when
they've read or seen some of the more
infamous entry things you've said not
buzz like speed you're gonna take
BuzzFeed article a buzzfeed article
seriously Pierce what kind of journalist
s I'll I'll give you a second I'll let
you talk I won't just interrupt all the
time like you
uh 22 from watching my father's gone
from a man who minded in women's studies
in college he was kind and in touch with
his emotions treated all people men and
women around him with kindness to a man
who says that whenever he sees an
effeminate male stranger he gets an
overwhelming urge to murder them he
loves podcasts he listens to a lot of
podcasts I know he's listened to Andrew
Tate let's stop for a second let's be
professional here peers because you're a
professional asifi firstly she said did
you say that my father when
she said my father has a father that's a
full-grown man firstly so we're talking
about my impact on children you just
talked about full-grown man here
secondly I've never talked about
murdering effeminate men and anything
online ever on in any context ever so I
don't know why they have taken some
random person I've never met in the
world who's full grown an adult and come
to their own conclusion so I've never
met and lumped his name in with mine
that is absolutely unfair on every level
I didn't watch I didn't read this video
I didn't read this BuzzFeed article but
after hearing the first point I know
it's trash that is complete garbage of
the reason this man believes what he
believes I have seen a quote from you
and you can tell me what you feel here
about this sure you talk about people
don't want to see men dressed up in
dressy transgender that's not exactly
what I said I said what did you say I
said the reason I am so popular and I'm
so famous is that there's a large
contingent of men who don't want to wear
makeup who still want to make money go
to the gym be strong drive a fast car be
traditionally masculine and don't want
to be shamed for that and they don't
want to be called toxic for that that is
the reason I'm so massively famous that
is what do you think of transgender
people that's nothing to do with me I'm
not transgender and I don't understand
the issue like they do they can do
transphobic do you you've consider
yourself that transfer well afraid uh
would it kind of yeah I don't live in
fear my friend I I have no problem you
have a dislike of transgender people I
don't know any transgender people you
have a dislike of what they stand for
what they are no why would I I don't
know that's not my issue that's not my
issue and that's actually quite
interesting because when I was attacked
a lot of these stupid articles like
BuzzFeed because it's ridiculous that
whole that first point proves anyone
with a brain knows that that's garbage
when they attacked me they lump a whole
bunch of things in together they say
misogynistic racist transphobic they
just put them all together around I
mixed race by the way I don't know where
they get these they just get these
buzzwords
I completely agree it's crazy and I've
had the same thing done to me okay and
I'm not calling you anything I'm asking
you what you personally believe you are
I it's not an issue I discuss what I do
discuss is that you support transgender
people Trent I I support individual
liberty I'm a Libertarian so you support
transgender people sure
sure why not exactly yeah so but my
point is as a whole you're saying that
I'm saying I don't want to see men in
dresses I'm saying no I'm just poor gay
people sure yeah I'm saying there's a
large contingent of men in the world who
like the idea of the traditional
masculine view of the world who feel
happy when they watch 80s action heroes
with big muscles and they run around and
there's nothing toxically masculine
about having a fast car and a beautiful
girlfriend and making a bunch of money
nothing at all absolutely and those are
the people who are my fans but the
problem is okay I'm going to interrupt
you just to say this no no okay but this
you're saying that I have a problem with
hit men in dresses I'm saying no the
people who watch my contact question
you've answered yeah but the people who
watch my content don't want to see men
in dresses clearly I don't wear a dress
well why they're watching your content
no you're not wearing a dress no but
that's the point I'm making that's the
point I was making there's a large
contingent of men who are not interested
in the things that's perhaps the YouTube
algorithms trying to feature look when
you support masculinity and masculine
traits I'm with you right okay so you
agree a man should protect and provide
for a woman absolutely okay so you agree
if you were walking down the street with
a woman you'd be you'd be responsible
with her safety uh yeah cool absolutely
so if that woman wanted to walk alone I
don't think I have authority over the
world as we do that okay so let me ask
you another question Pierce because we
are professionals let's say your woman
decided she wanted to take a nice little
walk through the south side of Chicago
at 2 A.M and she wanted you to go with
her and you were responsible for
fighting and dying on the spot if she
was attacked don't you think you would
say to her no we're not going out right
now it's not safe yes okay so you'd have
authority to make the decisions no it
wouldn't so I would say I don't think
you should if she decides to it's her
own volition well if she decides you're
not going to stop I have no power to
stop her completely but you think you do
no I don't think I Powers no I think I
have power to make the decision I think
no that's not something if you have the
power to make the decision you have hard
to stop it no because that's where we
differ that's why I think it's
interesting about you I don't think you
really think through what you're saying
I think through what I'm saying because
we're so careful but Andrew you've
literally just said is that you have the
power to stop no I said I don't have the
power to stop her I'm not going to lock
her in the room I'm saying that so she
wants to go on her own then she's going
to go then but it doesn't have authority
to stop okay but as a couple if we're
going to sit there and decide if we're
going to take this would I feel a sense
of responsibility for a safety
absolutely agreed absolutely
power or authority to stop her doing it
no no of course not so let me finish
Spears you're not going to stop her
walking out the hotel of course it's her
decision she's a sovereign individual my
point is that usually in a couple people
have you'd sit there as a team and you
discuss and perhaps on certain issues
the woman will know more about X and
she'll decide X and the man might know
more about why and he'll decide why so
I'm saying if we're as a couple and
we're sitting there and deciding as a
couple as a team and she says she wants
to take this late night stroll I'm going
to say you know what I'm going to veto
this one I'm going to call do you
believe in this dangerous crime which
two degree would give me in that
particular scenario I'd agree Authority
if she said I don't want to listen to
you it doesn't give you Authority she
says I don't want to listen to you
Andrew I want to go on that walk then
what can I do say well then I don't have
authority I hope I wish you the best I
love then you don't have authority cool
then it's a semantic argument not really
I think it's the complete opposite of
what you said you had which was
Authority no problem Pierce no problem
but I think I think we actually about
what do you
Pierce you know you I feel like Pierce
knows he's wrong in this situation
whatever whatever Pierce not depression
do you believe depression is a real
thing I believe that feeling depressed
is real I don't believe depression as a
clinical disease is real no really
correct you don't believe people can be
clearly depressed I think PTSD is very
real I've unfortunately I have some
friends who suffer from that I know that
feeling depressed is real I believe that
the number one power you have against
these things are taking trying to take
control of your own mind and affecting
your own life I believe that it's not
healthy to hand over all your power and
believe that depression is an outside
disease that you can't affect I know
that when I've had difficult periods in
my life and also many of my friends like
I've said suffer from PTSD and been
through terrible things I've lived a
very difficult life and I know people
who have that the things that made them
feel better is when they woke up and
said you know what I'm not going to
allow this to damage me anymore I'm
going to take responsibility I'm going
to get up and I'm going to fight this as
hard as I can and by the way on that I
agree so my favorite speech is the Rocky
Balboa
you've got to let me sure interject when
I didn't agree with you right where I
don't know
oh
he has let you interject Pierce yeah
that's lecha interject what's that you
have to like
is that there's no such thing as
clinical depression there absolutely is
well it's a proven scientific medical
reality there's a different argument
about have we gone a bit too soft right
in the schools and all the rest of it
absolutely yeah do I think some people
moan and whine too much about their lot
in life definitely okay are we a
victimhood society 100 okay is there
such a thing as clinical depression
absolutely so and my argument is that if
you actually bracket everybody who's not
deleted depressed and doesn't have the
genuine medical condition then actually
if millions of people are deemed to have
depression the ones who really need the
help don't get it well that's my point
well that can that that I would agree
with you're right I think it's certainly
overused terms there is such a thing
called no I don't and that to me is a
damaging view okay well let me explain
why if someone comes to me and says I'm
clinically depressed or I feel very very
sad I would say the first thing you need
to do is stop accepting the identity of
a clinically depressed person stop
accepting you have no control over this
and what you need to do is stop
identifying that way and let's work
together to try and fight against the
reason an eminent doctor in the world
who would tell you there is no such
thing as clinical depression we would
not tell you that I think I think you're
simply Beyond I think Johann Hari wrote
a book saying exactly that my friend
he's not an imminent doctor no but he is
I said depression wasn't real long ago
and was attacked for it then Johann Hari
wrote a book which actually because he
wrote a book Proof of me right most
people yeah he's a journalist sure and
and my point is that a lot of people who
are clinically depressed are suffering
with something in their life and if you
fix the problem in their life perhaps
they won't feel depressed anymore but
it's not a disease but Andrew you're not
situational what do they say
any guy that's depressed give him a
million dollars 10 hot [ __ ] and
muscles you're you ever felt depressed
he's just African he doesn't
okay you ever know a depressed person
you think they would be you think they'd
be depressed if they were in really
great shape and had 10 girls and a
million dollars
says they're depressed because they're
broke and you get the money they're okay
yeah yeah I'm like I feel like with a
girl you give us youth
you give us it's like youthist money to
us I swear to God like I feel like I
would take Eternal youth over like yeah
like looking young or whatever oh easy
most girl I bet you most girls if you
said you could have a million dollars
but you'd have to like Drop two points
and looks most girls would say no
You're simply wrong
if that's what you believe Pierce that's
what I believe I don't believe in things
that take power away there is not an
eminent doctor in the world would agree
with this I think you know more than
doctors I can't become clinically
depressed
why do you know because I don't believe
it
I can't be haunted by a ghost if I don't
believe in ghosts well let's say I'm
never going to die because I don't
believe in it it's ridiculous perhaps
but if it allows me to live a life where
I feel happy again this is that little
area where you lose me no I don't lose
you somebody with your following so
thousands of people the thousands of
people who have emailed me saying my
doctor told me I was clinically
depressed and it's a disease that I have
got in my brain and I can't be fixed and
I started listening to you and I
realized that that's not the case and I
can fix my own life and you're the only
person who has ever helped me thousands
of people that email me that exact email
if you think you are single-handedly
curing people of clinical depression you
are living in Cloud Cuckoo I am reading
the emails of people who I have cured of
clinical depression you're reading
emails from people who have believed you
when you say there isn't such a thing
and they've probably never been
diagnosed to Legal depressed they just
want to go along with what Andrew dates
says I don't think so and I think your
view of that is that view is dangerous I
I I respect that you think my view is
dangerous and I respect you have the
right to view that to think that I think
that clinical depression I actually
agree with you as massively over
diagnosed I've already said that PTSD is
a very real thing I've already said I
didn't so hang on okay again you
misquoted me I I did not say clinical
depression is massively over diagnosed I
said that people who claim to be
depressed but don't have clinical
depression I think that is massively
overblown right in other words there are
a lot of people who just have a bad day
yeah and declare I've got depression
yeah and I I say well have you been to a
doctor have you been clinically
diagnosed if you have and you have
clinical depression that's one thing but
if you haven't we could probably work on
some mental strength and resilience
skills with you but a clinically
depressed person has a an absolutely
proven medical condition that is beyond
their control not according to me and
many others my friend well what do you
know about it honestly I know I know
that the doctor are you not trained are
you I'm not a doctor a psychiatrist
you're none of those things sure you're
a guy on the make he's done very well
for himself bouncing stuff off much of
which I agree with as you've seen in the
interview but some of which is ludicrous
and that's one of them it's not
ludicrous it is it's not you said to me
we're in a victim whose Society has got
to stop and we're there okay at the
moment you try and deny clinical
depression I believe feeling depressed
is real I do not believe it's a disease
that you catch from the sky and you
cannot affect I believe that no matter
what happens I believe you have control
of your own mind and you can fight
against it I believe if you change your
circumstances in your life you may feel
different I'll give you a quick example
I had a guy who emailed me saying who's
clinically depressed he was going to
kill himself
I obviously am not a psychiatrist I'm
not a doctor I told him because I
replied to my emails I said have you
been to a psychiatrist he said yes I'm
clinically depressed I've been on these
pills this amount of time about
antidepressants it doesn't work I said I
don't know what to say to besides this
and he said he lost his girlfriend
that's why I became clinically depressed
I said listen go to the gym get a
six-pack first once you've got a
six-pack email me again
you still feel like killing yourself I
don't know what else to say to you but
I'd say strong body is a strong mind GO
train
he went he started sending me progress
pictures emailing me him getting better
better shape and eventually got six-pack
he's not a professional bodybuilder and
he said I can't believe I was
considering that I feel so much better
Etc the doctor was telling him he was
clinically depressed and couldn't cure
it he started taking control of his own
life and now he felt better now I'm not
saying it's the case for everybody I'm
just saying my question have you seen
the guy's medical records of course not
I just told you the student is taking
his word for it oh I am taking the words
of a man who emailed me with a bunch of
medication and specifics you know
denying proven science because one guy
writes to you who you help and you've
not seen any evidence you ever had
clinical depression diagnosed I'm
denying the idea that on the back of it
you go on your your rants in public to
tens of millions of people denying
something because this guy writes to you
and says he had it and you cured him and
I think that's a dangerous mindset oh my
goodness
it's not dangerous tell okay what's
dangerous Pierce to tell tell a guy to
get jacked okay
um you can feel depressed but it's like
okay what are you gonna do let's say
let's say you have this diagnosis
let's say clinical depression's real
okay I'm not a doctor I don't know
what what are your options you can
either
try to fix it
it's like I understand what you're
saying with the ghost because it's funny
I always say I might believe in ghosts
but I just don't for my my sanity
because it's like easier if I don't and
I've said the same thing with like ADHD
because I've been told from a young age
um that I have ADHD and I was actually
on medication for it for a second but I
was like I think it's just easier if I
just pretend I don't have it because
like what's the matter often be
medicated forever no
no like they're trying to they're trying
to dim my light nasty you can't
yeah that so I understand what he's
saying he's saying he's saying that if
you believe in something you give it
power and I've thought about this too
with um with how do I put it like
there's just been certain times in my
life where I'm like oh I think
something's wrong and I'm just like well
I don't believe in it
like like mentally you know what I mean
like and I feel like every time I used
to think I had anxiety and then I just
like decided I didn't
another guy I think I was just doing it
to myself I was probably just
overthinking
I was like I'll just think less my dad
says I should think more especially
before things I say on the internet
sometimes but I said dad you don't want
me to be anxious I'm gonna think less
and it's funny because a couple years
ago I was actually struggling with like
anxiety a little bit and nothing like I
see some y'all on Tick Tock nothing like
you guys like nothing like you guys
don't put me in that boat and my dad was
like okay what what happens when you get
anxious I'm like I'll just think of
these things and he's like well why
don't you just like not think of them
and I'm like Dad I can't help it and
he's like well why don't you just go for
a run and I was like
well that sounds like a lot of work I'll
just try to not think of it
like I'm not really a runner it looks
like I get carried away dad
that's fine that's why you don't have a
responsible view of your influence over
disagree it's very responsible because
I'm saving people's lives I hate that
term like oh you don't have a
responsible view if you have an idea
that a lot of people disagree with and
some people can misinterpret it's like
I'm
okay I I'm on it is not my
responsibility to keep your kids off the
internet
if you if you're a grown adult you
should be able to understand that
there's nuance
I honestly think you should be able to
understand that at like 16. you should
be able to understand that like people
take things out of context you should be
able to understand it here you should be
able to hear an idea you don't like and
not go do it and not go to the extreme
if you're an adult look it that is not
my fault if you're over the age 18 and
for anyone under the age 18 that watches
my content it
talk to your parents tight is not my job
to get your kids off the internet nobody
is stopping any of you from not giving
your kids phones nobody's stopping any
of you from putting passcodes on your
computer my mom would let me watch TV up
to a certain age like I understand like
you might say oh you can't avoid it I'm
I'm a solution minded if I really didn't
want my kids on the internet it would
not be I don't have kids but like
assuming I did I swear to God they would
not be like oh you can homeschool them
like if there's if there's a will
there's a way that's my point that's my
point disagree that if you're dying if
you have if you feel depressed I
disagree that you cannot affect it and
change your life and take control and
fix yourself and feel happier I disagree
with you do you think do you think I
refuse to accept that there are people
out there who cannot become happy
contented individuals I refuse to accept
we live in a world where God has created
people who no matter how hard they work
and how good their life becomes can't be
happy I don't accept that I accept that
the universe is a very giving place and
that God loves all of us and if you try
your best and you work hard you can
become a better person person and I also
will argue with you and I'll counter the
point that you sitting here on your
platform telling people they have
clinical depression there's nothing they
can do about it it's far more data okay
well then if they have clinics why do
you misquote no because you're saying
being misquotes no you're saying if
people have clinical depression
they go to a doctor and they get
diagnosed and they get help then I would
argue the point that's something
opposite of what you just said I said I
would argue the point that if somebody
has depression of any kind whether it's
clinical whether it exists or not
whether they feel depressed or not
whatever they're taking control of their
life taking personal responsibility and
working hard is always going to be the
positive best thing they can possibly do
for their life going forward
so sitting here saying I don't believe
in clinical depression you don't believe
in depression no I don't I believe that
people can take control and fight
against things I believe in personal
sovereignty right it's fine good so we
agree no we don't yes we do no we're
done beers are on my side you're afraid
of being canceled along with me I said
to you from the start that's all I agree
with a lot of what you say completely
sometimes I'm taking you to task over
the stuff I don't agree with sure and
I'm just not sure you understand why
it's wrong which is in itself quite
revealing let me talking to you about
Alex we're talking about Alex Jones
right I will never sign with a TV
network
they will not they will not do that to
me oh my God and I I don't like being
like controlled unless I'm your property
[Laughter]
no before like I swear to go to the TV
network said I couldn't say something I
swear to God I would just want to say it
more I would just want to say a bit of
history with each other to get me
deported from the United States did he
yeah what is your view of Alex Jones I
think that Alex Jones is a sovereign
individual who very much like the Rabid
left deserves a chance to speak on his
points of view I think that the truth on
issues is usually somewhere in the
middle between two extremes do you think
Sandy Hook was staged I don't know
anything about Sandy Hook really you
know he's just been sued by the families
for millions and millions I have no idea
you don't know about it no so why would
you support someone in public you know
nothing about the most infamous when
have I supported him in public you have
supported him in public I've been on
this podcast yeah but you said nice
things about it I say nice things about
lots of people what do you think about
Alex Jones I said nice things about you
pierce that's fine
so to sit and say that I've been on a
podcast and I say nice things about it
you support his right to speak about
things like Sandy Hook I don't know
Sandy Hook I don't know and you know
what it was It was a by shooting of
school children okay but to sit and and
he's actually no no let's stop for a
second please don't interrupt me
the here's why you're I know why you're
good at your job first you interrupt
people a lot which is good it's a good
skill so you're right and then you're
gonna prove me right the timing is good
here's exactly what I did I only
interrupt people like you when you
either
refuse to answer the question or answer
a completely different one sure and I
want to remind you of what the question
was found or when you misquote me back
which you've done repeatedly through the
interview where you say you see peers
you agree with me and the viewer who's
been watching will go no he didn't cool
no problem the other thing you do is you
try and set these traps like now so
you're saying what's the Trap you think
I'm sitting you're saying that I agree
with every single point of view a man
has I literally didn't say that you're
saying well you support Alex Jones why
did you misquote me because you're
saying you support Alex Jones and you
said he you've been on his podcast and
he said this
I don't know what do you think about
exchange I don't know everything he said
what do you think of him I think I think
on his podcast he was cordial I think he
was professional on his podcast I've
also done podcasts with rabid leftists
and and people who openly hate me is it
wrong I do a podcast circuit so I don't
know everything he's ever said when
somebody like I don't know what so I
don't know what you're trying to say get
me here because I didn't get a word it's
pretty it's oh Pierce he has let you get
a word in he has luck to get a lot of
words it's a lame trick if you let me
get a word in I will tell you let's go
Alex Jones said that Sandy Hook didn't
happen it was staged by actors okay this
compounded the appalling grief of the
families of those poor 20 children okay
who were gunned to Pieces by a lunatic
with an AR-15 semi-automatic rifle they
were already Greek stricken beyond
belief and this guy pulled petrol onto
that grief quite deliberately to make a
huge amount of money from his Infowars
fake news [ __ ] and as a result a lot
of the families have now sued him and
they've won and he's gonna have to pay
back tens maybe hundreds of millions of
dollars in Damages to these families and
quite hundreds of millions I bet he
regrets that story oh I bet he regrets
that one he's like you know what I might
and that's the hard thing about being a
conspiracy theorist it's like sometimes
you're right sometimes you miss and I
guess if you miss this they might sue
you for everything you own I'm glad I'm
not in that industry I'm glad right it
wouldn't do anything about the pain he
calls them some of them actually have
people turn up outside their houses with
guns because Alex Jones had told them
that these parents were making it all up
they were all staged actors it was all
run by the government so I simply say to
you now I've told you that what is your
view of Alex Jones
I don't see why any of that has to do
with me I I it's very interesting I've
done the guys podcast I know him well he
was professional and courteous to me
when I meet somebody and they show me
respect I show them back respect that's
what I do as I dig with you you respect
him I if somebody shows me respect I
show them respect so I don't know I
don't know if Hitler says you respect
you'd respect him back if that that's a
stupid question it's not it's a logical
extension of your argument no if in 1931
I was walking through Germany and a man
come up to me and said sorry for bumping
into you I'd say sorry no problem mate I
shall respect that I don't know what are
you trying to say I sanctioned the
Holocaust he literally just said if
somebody respects you you respect them
back I say if somebody shows me respect
I show respect back that's a good way to
go through life whoever it is if
somebody shows me respect and is
courteous to me I'm courteous fact I can
respect somebody who caused such misery
and pain too I have no idea the
specifics of the thing you're discussing
I don't understand any of it I don't
know anything about it when you've told
me your version of events when did you
go on the podcast
I was on the podcast about four four
times in the last four years I did one
relatively recently it's a full time
four times you went on Alex Jones's
podcast correct promoting him helping
him making I don't think he was
promoting and helping him because well
it's his podcast well yeah but I've been
on the podcast of people who absolutely
hate me I've been on liberal left-wing
podcast I've been a feminist I know you
just sat here saying I'm I'm I would
like you to agree perhaps we can agree
on this point that I'm not a feminist I
go on feminist podcasts I can do a
podcast circuit I do not feminist I
don't know what do you think a feminist
is well let's not change subject here
Pierce stay on the side crazy
now you mentioned feminism completely
but you're trying to you say you're
trying to get away from the point
because what you did is you're trying to
say because I did a podcast I sanction
all this person's views and I'm saying I
do five podcasts a week I do five
podcasts a week and I don't sanction 100
the views of any other person on the
planet because I'm an individual and
here's an individual views as do you so
I don't know why you're trying to come
at me with one of his views and pretend
that's something it was a pretty big
view no but it's it's a lame trick
appears and you're better than this so
let's move on
had a podcast would you go on it
sure you would great okay let me know
what you're talking about Vladimir Putin
had a podcast to go on it if Joe Biden
had a podcast I'd go on it if a feminist
has a podcast I'll go on it it appears
Morgan has a podcast I'll go on it if
Alex Jones I mean I don't see the point
you're making but what about my podcast
just barely things
there's no point here you're just you're
digging but there's nothing to find well
I'm not I'm taking your position that if
somebody shows you respect you respect
them I think that I'm saying there are
lots of people in the world I do not
respect if Vladimir Putin showed me in
respect I would not respect him but
that's your opinion I would go on
Vladimir Putin's podcast I feel like we
would agree on some things I'd be like
Putin this feminism thing trash am I
right like he doesn't strike me as a guy
that's pro-feminism
I think I found some common ground I
wouldn't you know say he's like I hear I
don't really know much about Russia what
he he probably watches my show
oh because he doesn't like feminism I
already watched my [ __ ] he seems like a
busy man like a poo in if you're out
there
yeah come on my show
yeah but no it's my view okay that's
your view well your still view is you
would you're sitting here
peers saying that I'm on uncensored show
and in your intro you said that it's
important that we don't have Echo
Chambers and we have very correct and
that we have varying opinions sure but
then you're saying the people you don't
like you wouldn't go on their podcast no
no so you are a hypocrite no no
oh my God understand what censorship
means do you like a lot of words we've
had problems with today you're just
saying you what you're just what do you
think censorship means no but the point
I'm trying to make here hang on what do
you think censorship means don't hide
from the fact that you're saying you
will only do podcasts with people you
like why do you think that's censorship
no that's your that's your prerogative
My Prerogative is I'll just do with
censorship I'll discuss I'll discuss
opinions with anybody and I've done hard
left wing why are you not asking me
about the podcast I've done for the
people who are hard liberals by the way
I don't care whether they're left or
right extremist to me uh all nuts right
then we agree yes so perfect good next
subject all right here's my next podcast
with extremister more fun in my opinion
it's a very serious case here Jesus and
before you move on sorry Pierce but
before you move on I do find it kind of
disingenuous and I know we're on our
show and and I don't have a personal
problem with you but it is kind of
disingenuous to try and sit here and
lump me in with something with some
school shooting that's nothing to do
with me I was I have nothing to do I
mean on any level let me respond any
level let me explain like you've just
said you've been on this podcast four
times in four years since he said the
whole thing was staged I don't know
anything and I simply and I think the
fact that a smart guy like you wants me
to believe you had no idea that Alex
Jones who's been in the news now for the
last two years have been sued by these
families for the most heinous thing
imaginable of pouring petrol onto their
grief by claiming that shooting was
stage the fact that you're pretending
you didn't know about any of that it's
not about pretending you've been on
being on his podcast four times
supporting him and making him money so
damn right I'm going to call you out
when I do a podcast if you think I spend
time analyzing the point of view that
every that of that person and everything
they've ever said for years beforehand
well years it was minutes years and
years
that when did you last year you were
trying to lump me in and attack me for a
person whose podcast I do having a view
is absolutely childish because because
I've done a bunch of podcasts I've done
a bunch of podcasts with people who are
advocating for things okay that I do not
agree with on every single level in fact
most of my podcasts are me disagreeing
with people so it's completely crazy
that you're trying to lump me in with
that that's cheap I think that's cheap
you are completely misconstruing the
point of what I'm saying I think
deliberately no no what you're trying is
a cheap train and I'm just making it
clear today I'm just curious where
you're like where your moral line is
it's a cheap trick it's your moral life
I disagree with the points of view with
the majority of the people I do podcasts
with so it's a very cheap trick you're
trying here so people invent vile things
to make themselves rich off the back of
families of little kids who've been
blown to pieces with a machine gun
or a semi-automatic version of a machine
gun I think that is actually a line I
would I wouldn't cross I wouldn't be
happy to go on someone's podcast when
they've been responsible for doing that
it's not about political views or
differences of opinion over facts it's
about somebody deliberately inventing a
pack of lies to compound the grief of
families and I just I'm curious you
don't think you have any need to go down
any kind of moral quandary about people
like that before you continue to allow
them to use you for their own promotion
he didn't use me he didn't use me on the
podcast because we disagreed and
discussed points like we're doing with
you right now did you call him out on
that are you using me we didn't discuss
that I'm not using I'm giving you a
platform most people aren't giving you
right oh giving who gets
who's more famous right now yeah Pierce
I I honestly barely know who you are I'm
beyond like as a 25 year old the
Fountain of Youth basically over here
except when an 18 year old's here
um
yeah
Andrew Tate's more famous he was doing
you a service by coming on your show
come on mine Andrew pull up to show the
world who you really are fantastic so
neither of us are using each other I'm
here on your show I'm providing you with
content you're giving me a platform and
nobody's using each other it's mutual we
don't agree on a whole bunch of issues
it's fine and here we are I think we've
had a robust exchange yeah just like
I've done on nearly every other podcast
and for if someone were to come and say
to me in the future that something
heaven forbid there's a skeleton in your
closet and some were to come to me and
say you were on Piers Morgan's show did
you know he's ex or he's done X I would
say that's absolutely nothing to do with
right but I make the same point
protecting you I don't I don't know what
you do I don't know your personal
guarantee I can guarantee one thing I
will not be inventing stories I have
families I hope you I hope I hope not I
hope you're a righteous person but I
don't know me to be a righteous person I
don't know I'm just saying that I just
think it's interesting that you have no
moral compulsion about going on people
moral compulsions it's about I don't
know what you do Pierce you could have a
bunch of skeletons in your closet my
friend I don't have a clue I'm here on
your TV show I'm sure we all have lots
of skeletons let me know let me ask let
me ask you this interesting about the
feminism thing sure do you identify as a
feminist I think that women and men are
fantastic both of us are fantastic I
think women reproduce I think women need
to be respected protected provided for I
think that modern feminism is kind of
hard for me to even truly what do you
think it means what is feminism I think
that the idea of feminism is that men
and women are equal
under the law do you believe that
completely we have to be treated
completely yeah but we are equal under
the law wouldn't you agree uh not really
I think there are still some issues in
the world where I mean certainly in
workplace the gender pay Gap remains ah
he does not still believe in the gender
pay Gap
I knew this man was a simp
oh my God okay
uh they're not treated equally in most
cases women well that can be discussed
the gender pay Gap I think that's
already stop it stop it we're treated
better
I'm so who's treated better an 18 year
old guy or an 18 year old girl let's
just drop look cut the [ __ ] who's
gonna get more help at work from the men
who's gonna get more special favors
who's who's going to get extra training
yeah it's like
just gonna get the doors literally
opened for her
I'm so clever
I think that there's actually women
should go to work I think women should
work completely you did why wouldn't
they because in the parts of the country
of the world you were mentioning earlier
that have different views of women they
don't go to work in the parts of the
world that person from the podcast was
from for the point I made yeah they
didn't but I don't live in those parts
of the world I think women should be
free to work if they choose I think it's
very important that
hmm
we can return that too
the family unit remains I do believe
that the most in my personal view the
most important and respectful thing a
woman can do is become a mother I think
that having children is a beautiful
thing uh but obviously if women wants to
work and wants to have a career
especially now with paternity leave a
maternity leave and she can manage to do
both why wouldn't I want women to work I
don't know why anyone would ever assume
I don't want women to work or think
women can't work because I said that I
should keep them safe sometimes good no
but it's interesting because you have to
look at this Pierce it's interesting how
people extrapolate Andrew said that
women that he's responsible for a
woman's safety and he said that that
gives him authority to make decisions
for her safety and that's been
misconstrued and he's a bad person he
believes that women are property so but
now we believe that Andrew doesn't
believe in love Andrew doesn't believe
women should work and I don't know where
all of that comes from well that's why
I'm glad we've had a chance completely I
believe women are sovereign individuals
and they can make any choice they so
desire I think that it's important that
we remember that a man has a duty I
think I certainly in my relationship
have a financial responsibility to
provide for my woman my woman would
never have to work unless she wanted to
because I'm the kind of person who works
hard enough
young men though all aspire to be like
you should young men aspire to work very
hard have no criminal record become
multi-millionaires protect and provide
for the women close to them be Sovereign
so they can stand up and have their own
points of view in face of cancellation
be able to not be mentally intimidated
when they go on national TV and there's
traps set up for them yeah I believe
that confidence strong men who who stand
up and protect and provide for women are
a good thing for the world and the good
Force for the world and I don't think
that I put a magic spell on anybody I
think there's a whole bunch of men in
the world who understands my value and
if if men grow up to be like me you're
gonna have a whole bunch of people with
no criminal record dedicated athletes
who protect and provide for the people
close to them are fantastic for the
economy and we're and I'm not I'm
certainly not the worst influence out
here peers you have little Naz twerking
on the devil on music videos which our
children are digesting you have uh
drillar is singing about stabbing people
to death in the middle of a knife crime
epidemic you have rabid uh Psychopaths
on whether the right or the left
announcing violence on the other side
you have all these insanities in the
world and because I sit here and say I
yeah perhaps now you've you've laid out
and it offended you I understand
okay cool I just read you the things you
read things that you said they could be
offensive and some people are offended
well some people definitely were
offended absolutely that's fine and
honestly I think some of the things you
said were genuinely offensive and
misogynist okay so they offended you so
like I said earlier so they offended you
which is fine I said they offended you
you interrupted me now you're saying
they offended you which is fine and the
but the point I'm trying to make is this
I'm not the devil there are certainly
worse people than me
and I'm saying that my core tenants for
the people who don't understand me are
self-accountability so I'm accountable
for everything I've ever said my core
tenants are responsibility so I'm
responsible for everything I've said my
court tenants are traditional
masculinity to a degree which involves
protecting and providing for women and
I'll make another Point another Point
here that's very very that's very that
needs to be said
the number of women who have stood up
and stuck up for me is ignored thousands
of women are making videos saying I've
met entertain such a nice guy I wish I
had a man like Andrew Tate who felt
responsible to protect and provide for
me you know what I I do belong to my
husband that's why I married him and I
love him we ignore the thousands of
women who stood up and prepared and and
stood by me and said everything I said
is true and we're taking a very vocal
minority who have taken things I've said
and are pretending to be absolutely
Nutley devastated by them for some
reason time out sure you've had a good a
good run there sure an inquiry yeah he
let him finish his sentence you know
this week found that a 14 year old girl
Molly Russell died from an active
self-harm while suffering from
depression and the negative effects of
online content the coroner said she was
exposed to material I don't know is he
gonna try to pin this on Andrew
foreign
become a much more serious depressive
illness and she's very sadly took her
life that's that's absolutely disgusting
right her father terrible her father's
campaign for better protections against
potentially dangerous social media
algorithms right it says that the
particularly graphic content she saw
romanticized acts of self-harm
normalized her condition and focused on
a limited and irrational view without
any counterbalance of normality
first of all what is your response to
that nothing to do with you yes that's
the first thing yeah it is nothing to do
with me the fact that a 14 year old girl
took her life is truly sad the world we
live in today is
the world we live in the fact that
something like that happened is almost
mind-blowing to me that's truly that's
truly sad I actually feel sad and sad to
see something like that the fact that
they just said this romanticizing the
Gory element I don't know what she was
watching some kind of suicide videos
that I don't know where these things are
you think the tech companies should be
much tougher about stuff like this
I don't know what kind of things she
watched obviously I have to be a
professional here I think that the tech
companies need to do their best to
protect people I guess to a degree but
it's a slippery slope isn't it and then
they use this slippery slope to to
silence some people and to do right and
I think that's a I think it's a really
fine line and it's a complicated line it
is very I was interested when you did an
interview with the times Hugo Rifkin
he's a very good journalist we did a big
interview with him and it was
interesting to meet his conclusion
because he kind of concluded that
although he found a lot of the things he
said
awful and offensive and he didn't like
them and he didn't want to be that kind
of person that would say those kind of
things
nor could he actually work out exactly
what you've done which deserves Mass
wipeout by all the tech firms I thought
it was an interesting conclusion I don't
you know I don't know the answer to that
other than the reason I mentioned the
Molly Russell case not because that has
anything to do with you at all and I
reiterate that thank you I simply ask
you this what has come clear to me in
the interview is that a lot of things
you say you wouldn't say now that you've
said before but I'd say them differently
yeah right so to me that's an acceptance
not just that you want to get back on
platforms because maybe that was one of
the reasons you were no platform but
that you've recognized and understood
the potential harm to the wrong kind of
impressionable mind
by some of the things you've said would
that be fair I think that's 80 fair I
recognize and understand that with
massive Fame
you have to be more careful about being
misconstrued like I said earlier one
percent of people misunderstanding you
doesn't matter with a small audience it
matters with a very large audience with
power comes responsibility I still
believe the things I say I do not want
to be a negative Force for the world I
also understand that I am a man who's
lived a very difficult nuanced life and
I am capable of making nuanced points
that may be misunderstood by teenagers
however that can be said about anybody
and everything every opinion online can
be misunderstood by children trying to
protect children from the Internet is a
very interesting subject in and of
itself because I would argue that 80 of
the content on the Internet is can be
negative or detrimental to a young mind
that doesn't understand the world yeah
I'd argue that all of it we just talked
about music videos and dancing on the
devil all this stuff all this stuff is
dangerous by the way I think you make a
very good point on that so a lot of
these rap stars the lyrics the videos I
think far exceed anything that you've
been accused of doing completely because
in a lot of cases some of them promote
non-consensual activity with people
right and I just think that crosses the
line you have as far as I've seen you
haven't crossed that line no I haven't
and I and this is the thing and I've
been vilified not because of the things
I say because much more extremist
content already exists on the internet I
think the reason I've been attacked and
vilified is because of the popularity
because I became so massively famous not
because of what I was actually saying so
as a professional I analyze that and I
understand that okay I'm massively
famous now and certain things have been
taken out of context however I still do
believe I'm a Force for good in the
world and I'm not going to sit here have
you changed though I don't it's not
about changing what are these we're all
involved in Evolution how old do you
know I'm 36 36 right I bet you're a
different person to what you were when
you were 26. oh that's fine that's
absolutely so we all change and Mike you
know keep talking about being a good
person yeah I think if you're honest
with yourself yeah that you can see why
people found a lot of the stuff you've
said
problematic and misogynist and I think
you recognized you wouldn't express
yourself in that way again because
you've understood that it's caused a lot
of harm and that's really really what I
wanted to get to today was an
acknowledgment by you that these things
clearly
were said in the wrong way created the
wrong impression if you didn't mean them
no no do not admit I can therefore have
a malevolent influence when you have a
huge following yeah when you have a huge
following you certainly have to be a lot
more careful about how you get certain
points across that's absolutely a fact
Andrew I appreciate you coming all the
way from Romania I would use the essay I
regret nothing Pierce that's how it
ended thank you it's been an interesting
conversation and I thank you for having
it cheers well that's it for me whatever
you're up to final thoughts
um Pierce Morgan I know you're soft kind
of a simp a little bit you interrupt a
lot
um seemed like a good like dude you know
I mean like nothing personal but like
yeah I meant everything I said
um also
um Andrew Tate come on my podcast
um also I think you should subscribe to
the channel and ring that notification
Bell sign up for one of our four
membership tiers okay if you want a
one-on-one call with me once a month
that's our fourth membership tier like
the video on your way out and I will
talk